bon allez on va parler alors là un sujet
qui je le sais là encore vous avez à
vous faire réagir et vous qui nous
regardent et également mois par les
sciences et sexualité oui étonnamment ça
marche ça match ensemble visiblement
puisque dans je t'aime et cetera sur
france 2 on a découvert ce que je
qualifierais mois de d'effrayantes
invention de deux chercheurs américains
regardaient vous allez me dire ce que
vous en pensez
des chercheurs américains aurait écrit
un algorithme en fait informatique
capable d'établir si un homme ou une
femme et homosexuels ou hétérosexuels
bisexuels et ainsi de suite
la technologie repose sur un échantillon
de près de 35 minutes images spatiales
postés sur des sites de rencontre et
selon les chercheurs ce système de
reconnaissance de sexualité fonctionne à
91 % pour les hommes
83% de certitudes pour les femmes comme
les chercheurs derrière cette
technologie le souligne un gouvernement
en effet un parti politique ou une
société multinationale pourrait donc se
servir des images que nous postons de
nous mêmes ou des images même de nos
enfants pour détecter sans notre
consentement je vous le rappelle notre
orientation sexuelle je vous souhaite
une bonne journée une bonne continuation
sur cet incident alors ce sont deux
chercheurs en psychologie informatique
de l'université de stanford qui ont eu
cette fumeuse idée qu'est ce que vous en
pensez je vous avoue que je vous ai un
peu induit ce rebond sans lui il ment
sur la chose mais que je trouve
particulièrement dangereux si ce n'est
pas ce que ça peut être en plus erroné
donc mais déjà faut les virer de
l'université de standford profondément
dangereux je rappelle quand même que
l'homosexualité est encore interdite
dans 72 pays dont il ya des
gouvernements qui peuvent se servir de
choses comme ça
mettre des gens en prison ou pire donc
c'est hyper grave
franchement je sais pas quoi ils pensent
quand ils en vendent ça moi ça me fait
gerber et surtout j'y crois pas on
espère que ça n'aura pas lieu mais c'est
extrêmement dangereux d'essayer de
mettre au point ce genre de choses non
c'est pas karim vous avez l'air plutôt
favorable non mais je suis pas favorable
c'est difficile de passer après et vous
et le sujet phare car mais après je peux
faire comme madame ka mate yama rade
et dire que c'est horrible évidemment
qu'à l'échelle mondiale et si c'est pour
des mains discriminatoire c'est horrible
mais bon on aimerait être fin que défend
d'escrimé voir quel intérêt de sable ans
et rien que votre camarade est hétéro bi
nous c'est que moi je vous parle moi je
vous parle vraiment à titre personnel
ouais mon rêve ce serait une application
qui existent que je scanne à la personne
et qu'on me dise combien ils gagnent
qu'est-ce qui fait comme métier
destiné au monde mais gagne 1,38 la
maison tout ce qu'il aime le jeu c'est
en moyenne où on serait tous en dans une
contenance de la main en fonction que je
veux dire c'est que je pense qu'il va
donner à cette application en termes
échelle mondiale et tout les risques
éventuellement et m'adresse
particulièrement s'attaquer à une
catégorie de population mais tout de
même on ne peut pas s'empêcher
d'imaginer que les mais c'est bien son
problème là c'est qu'elle pense oui
parce que je suis très bien va chercher
des applis va chercher des appuis sur
les salaires mais n'a rien à voir la
socialité pas quelque chose de très très
graves
franchement est-ce qu'il y en a chez les
ch'tis vous parler dans le vide ça
existe je suis sûr qu'ils existent parce
se classe que l'esa est évident mais ok
ils ont fabriqué sous marine qui dit que
l'intelligence artificielle mais ça
voudrait dire que dès la naissance
vous êtes ce que vous devez être et
c'est pas du tout le cas vous vivez vous
avez une histoire l'histoire de votre
vie elle va conditionner ce que vous
allez être à 16 18 20 40 ans donc c'est
complètement pipeau et justement la
qualité d'un être humain c'est toutes
ces différences qui font qu'il ya pa 38
min mais malheureusement ce genre
d'informations pourraient tomber dans
des mains mal intentionnées puisque il
se targue de en disant que les
prédictions sur leurs expériences
étaient exacts pour 91% pour les hommes
83 % pour les pour les femmes on peut
craindre le pire on peut imaginer qu'on
aie aie demandé à ces chercheurs tel
gouvernement tel état pour aller
chercher l'or donc ça voudrait dire si
on écoutait ségala qu'en fonction de la
morphologie de votre visage et de du
scam qu'on apprend de votre corps ça
veut dire mettre d'accord c'est pas nous
c'est drôle mais c'est extrêmement
dangereux
ah bah oui ça peut paraître dangereux
quand même mais vous oubliez un cas de
figure qui ça peut servir
m bah oui ces gens que tout le monde
connaît tout le monde en a autour d'eux
ce sont les gens qui est au resto
n'hésite trois heures sur la carte qui
sont hyper indécis que ça peut peut-être
quand même en donner leur dirai dépêche
toi prends ta décision est complètement
dépenses et je me suis dit peut-être
elle pense pas à ça vous vous pensé trop
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
nous en pensée avec le hashtag députés
est ce que vous estimez que ces
chercheurs en psychologie joue aux
apprentis sorciers que c'est extrêmement
dangereux est ce que vous dites que
toute façon c'est complètement faux et
farfelu et inapplicable en tout cas on
le souhaite que ce soit inapplicable